why did walking tall fall flat why did
the rundown get the runaround and how
did dwayne johnson save not just his
career but the entire fast and furious
franchise keep watching to find out
you couldn't ask for a more high profile
movie star debut than when dwayne the
rock johnson snagged the villain role
and mega sequel the mummy returns
despite only being in a small part of
the movie johnson was a huge part of the
mummy returns marketing leading to a 68
million dollar opening in a 435 global
hall johnson snagged 5.5 million dollars
for the prequel the scorpion king
bearing pizza money to him today but at
the time the highest salary ever for a
first time leading man johnson proved he
was worth the investment with the movie
bringing in 165 million dollars
worldwide then the rundown happened
whoops honestly the rundown is a really
solid action movie with a 69 critic
score on rotten tomatoes however by 2003
one-man army action movies were being
replaced by superheroes the movie
managed to pull in 80 million dollars
worldwide but with an 85 million dollar
price tag the underperformance of the
rundown nearly sent the rock scrambling
right back to the wrestling ring
fast and furious presents hobbs and shaw
may have caused a rift with the family
but it did pretty well for johnson's
bank account and for universal pictures
which bankrolled it this spin-off from
the fast and furious franchise was one
of the few bright spots of the dismal
summer box office of 2019 while it
certainly helps being part of a fast and
furious franchise that has racked up 6.5
billion dollars worldwide johnson's
global popularity played a huge part in
the success of hobbs and shaw all due
respect to tyrese gibson and chris
ludacris bridges but it seems unlikely a
perch and parker film would do nearly as
well so how well did hobbs and shaw do
with a mammoth 200 million dollar budget
20 million dollars of which reportedly
went to johnson's wallet hobbs and shaw
made 173 million dollars domestically
and 760 million dollars worldwide
2005 was a time of transition for
johnson the lukewarm box office response
to action picks like the rundown stalled
his efforts at becoming the next arnold
schwarzenegger however he hadn't yet
launched his dreadful macho guy in a
kid's movie phase exemplified by films
like race to witch mountain in this muk
was the appropriately titled doom
appropriately titled because that's
exactly what this movie meant critically
and commercially doom with an 18 credit
score and 34 audience score the video
game adaptation failed to transition
from the console to the big screen with
a 70 million dollar budget doom finished
its run earning 28 million domestically
and 58 million dollars worldwide added
marketing costs and it's estimated the
film likely lost around 82 million
dollars johnson was only a co-lead
opposite carl urban but his name and
face were plastered all over the
promotional materials so whether he was
in it for a few minutes or the whole run
time people who went to see it did so
because of him so the failure was
considered his i'm not supposed to
dwayne johnson's second appearance as
special agent luke hobbs is one of the
biggest hits on his resume this was fast
and furious 6 by the way and if you have
trouble remembering which furious movie
that was it was the one where hobbes
hires dominic in the family to take out
a mercenary whose second in command is
letty in exchange for a full pardon not
that the plot matters fast and furious 6
earned a whopping 238 million dollars
domestically and 789 million dollars
worldwide on a 160 million dollar budget
it is estimated to have made a profit
around 469 million dollars you could be
forgiven for thinking so what johnson
just latched onto a popular franchise
actually it was kind of the other way
around johnson's first furious movie
fast five was already a huge 44
improvement over the fast and furious
take of 359 million dollars johnson
helped the furious franchise level up in
a big way leading to his nickname
franchise viagra
dwayne johnson may have starred in
walking tall but he certainly wasn't
walking very tall at the box office the
rundown had disappointed with 80 million
dollars worldwide so johnson was looking
for a rebound and he did not get it
walking tall wasn't a course correction
so much has an even bigger detour than
the rundown walking tall got a dreadful
26 critic score and a barely fresh 60
audience score its box office was even
worse earning just 47 million dollars
worldwide johnson's series of bombs
showed while audiences were all in on
him being an added value to the already
popular mummy series they didn't see him
as a movie star yet he was still the
wrestler who acted as evidenced by his
continued billing as the rock but if he
was going to walk tall for real a change
was clearly in order that was a hell of
a homecoming party
the fast and furious and jumanji
franchises are similarly unusual because
they started as successful but not
spectacular box office performers only
to become major franchises later so
what's the common denominator
dwayne johnson johnson's impact on
jumanji might be more impressive than
fast and furious as jumanji wasn't even
a franchise before johnson it was a
well-remembered robin williams star
vehicle from 22 years earlier johnson
turned it into a franchise with 2017's
jumanji welcome to the jungle sony
wisely played it safe only spending 90
million dollars on the film and making
sure jumanji was front and center in the
film's marketing that and plastering the
stars mugs all over the marketing most
notably that of johnson it turned out to
be a good strategy jumanji welcome to
the jungle opened relatively small to
just 36 million dollars but it lagged it
out to an incredible 404 million dollars
domestically and 961 million dollars
worldwide for an estimated 781 million
dollar profit yep somehow someway the
jumanji series went from a has been to a
nearly 1 billion dollar franchise this
makes it not only one of johnson's
biggest hits but the biggest franchise
transformation ever
by 2006 dwayne johnson's movie star
career was off to a rocky start actually
it was straight up terrible the rundown
walking tall and doom had each bombed
demonstrating moviegoers weren't looking
for the next schwarzenegger and even if
they were it wasn't johnson so what's a
would-be macho one-man army movie star
supposed to do give the audience the
feels enter 2006's gridiron gang based
on a true story drama in which johnson
plays a probation officer and counselor
at a juvenile detention center who
teaches the inmates responsibility by
forming a football team if it feels like
you've seen this movie before critics
agreed panning it as cliche with a 42
score and audiences stayed away gridiron
gang earned 41 million dollars worldwide
even with a modest 30 million dollar
budget it lost about 19 million dollars
the only silver lining is that it
allowed johnson to demonstrate actual
acting ability which might have helped
him get another chance
the original 1995 jumanji was a solid
hit for robin williams but when the
studio tried to turn it into a franchise
a decade later with 2005's zathora they
made the mistake of not bringing back
williams as a result the movie was a
flop so after the success of 2017's
jumanji welcomed to the jungle the
studio had learned its lesson bringing
back johnson and his co-stars to
recapture the magic it worked 2019's
jumanji the next level was another smash
hit earning 316 million dollars
domestically and 800 million dollars
worldwide all right
bring it on
thanks to its modest 125 million dollar
budget it's estimated that jumanji the
next level earned around 550 million
dollars
that's some serious bank
dwayne johnson's movie career was in a
weird place in 2010 he'd headlined
several action movie bombs but found his
new niche starring in badass in a kid's
movie films like the game plan and tooth
fairy alas those brought to mind hulk
hogan's failed big screen career such as
the dreadful mr nanny sure they made a
little money but is that really the
direction anyone would want to take
their career certainly not johnson who
tried again to headline an action flick
in 2010s faster with a very modest 24
million dollar budget faster seemed sure
to make money if only because it was so
cheap to produce
yeah so much for that faster tanked out
of the gate and ran out of gas fast
earning 23 million domestically and 35
million dollars worldwide despite its
bargain budget faster still reportedly
lost about 13 million dollars back to
kitty movie hell for johnson not quite
he followed this up with 2011's fast
five which more than doubled the
worldwide gross of faster in its opening
weekend alone johnson's action movie
career didn't need to go faster it just
needed to go faster and furious sir
few franchises have followed a more
interesting trajectory than the fast and
the furious the series started strong in
2001 hit the skids then roared back not
only bigger than before but much bigger
and much of that can be chalked up to
the addition of johnson who changed the
franchise forever with 2011's fast five
but that wasn't the biggest hit in the
franchise the series high watermark came
with 2015's furious 7. you could tell
this film was meant for big things when
it opened to 147 million dollars
domestically a 50 million dollar bump
from the 97 million dollar opening of
fast and furious 6. furious 7 wasn't
done smashing franchise records earning
353 million dollars domestically on its
way to an incredible 1.5 billion dollars
worldwide nearly doubling the 789
million dollar worldwide gross of fast
and furious 6. furious 7 became one of
the top 10 highest grossing films ever
with a 190 million dollar budget furious
7 earned universal a profit of around
1.12 billion dollars furious 7 is
unequivocally johnson's biggest hit
handily topping the 781 million dollar
profit of jumanji welcome to the jungle
and 1.2 billion dollar gross of fate of
the furious not bad for a pro wrestler
turned actor
right there are bombs there are mega
bombs and then there's southland tails
it's appropriate the film is about a
potential nuclear annihilation as that
pretty much was the scale of this
disaster strangely southland tales
seemed like it might be just what
johnson's career needed in 2007
following a string of failures most of
johnson's mid-2000 uber was straight to
dvd quality so starring in critical
darling richard kelly's highly
anticipated follow-up to donnie darko
was probably meant to give him indie
cred
so much for that while southland tales
has recently received something of a
critical reappraisal at the time few
viewers liked it as its 39 critic score
and 41 audience score demonstrated even
worse was its box office gross ready for
this
southland tales made 364 607 000
worldwide
yep probably less than what a luke hobbs
movie makes on a tuesday afternoon
for the fast and the furious franchise's
eighth installment the series did what
nobody could have possibly predicted it
broke up the family and vin diesel's
dominic dom toretto was the one to do it
say what
honestly by this point the franchise
could have done just about anything and
still would have made boatloads of money
but just for the sake of thoroughness
here's the deets after dom fell into the
seductive clutches of charlize theron's
diabolical cipher there was only one man
who could bring the family together to
take on their former leader dwayne
johnson by this point johnson was almost
as much a part of this franchise as
diesel as despite the large ensemble
they were the only two featured on the
teaser poster with the provocative
family no more tagline that was enough
the fate of the furious opened to 98
million
and wound up bringing home 225 million
dollars domestically and 1.2 billion
dollars worldwide with a blockbuster
sized 250 million dollar budget the fate
of the furious still hauled in about 700
million dollars in profit at this point
it seems fair to say that johnson has
probably left the bombs behind for good
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]